show us who's behind the mask
[Applause]
another celebrity revealed on the mast
to singer what would make you do
something like put a pineapple on your
head and sing I will survive anything to
get on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
the over-the-top competition show
featured a brand-new batch of singing
celebs in disguise
[Music]
we'll have to keep watching the series
to find out who those secret stars are
but there is one celeb we do know who
was revealed last week he was with the
panelist and host Nick Cannon ahead of
the series premiere to figure out how
they keep things so hush-hush while
they're on set talk about how secret the
identities are private the producers are
just so I know nothing you know nothing
and even when like they like try to ban
us from talking to each other because
they don't want us to guess so like
we're not even allowed to talk about who
we think but do you really not know I
don't know I know add up I'm like I'm
trying to guess just like everyone else
and like it's funny because I'm standing
next to him it's alright looking at
their neck like yeah that's it that's
all that's a young neck yeah that Nick
can't be over 35 I know that Nick no
because I'm like trying to figure it out
but other than that they like keep them
in caves or a lair under the studio or
some way their agents put on masks to
disguise them on the way here dick you
know two words to describe it bonkers
[Music]